and that crash is pushing clark county
commissioners to take a look at the
policies within the exotic rental car
industry joe mohler attended today's
commission meeting where the topic was
placed in the spotlight joe joins us
live with what that means joe
county commissioner michael naff says
the crashes involving these exotic
rental cars is becoming far too common
and during today's county commission
meeting he instructed staff to start
looking into this industry
naft wants to take a look at how
companies obtain license and insurance
he says not enough drivers are trained
before hitting the road in exotic cars
he wants to make sure companies are
making sure drivers are safe and to make
sure those companies are operating
lawfully my hope is to help keep the
driver safe but as well as those
residents in our community who frankly
some of which are being terrorized by
people who come in here for the weekend
and have a good time have a joyride on
the strip or in our communities
following recent crashes with rented
cars such as the rolls royce friday in a
lamborghini in june the office of
traffic safety is also now collecting
fatal exotic rental crash data they
expect to release that information in
december or january
next the department of business
licensing will bring information and
improvements suggested improvements to
the next county commission meeting next
month reporting live joe mohler live
local now